[Musique]
une petite
enle et moi après et moi qui cour après
au milieu de la nuit mais qu'est-ce que
je lui ai
fait une petite idiote qui me joue la
grande scène de la femme
délé et qui veut me faire croire qu'elle
va se
noyer quel côté la scène mais qu'est-ce
que je lui ai fait qu'est-ce qu'elle me
reproche qu'est-ce qu'il lui a
pris lorsque je l'ai trompé elle l'
jamais
appris c'est pas elle qui s'approche tu
m'aimes vraiment dis-moi tu m'aimes tu
m'aimes tu m'aimes c'est tout ce qu'elle
sait dire en bouffant brasant quand je
voudrais dormir faut lui dire que je
l'aimer une petite fille en pleur dans
une ville en pluie où éit le nom de Dieu
elle a dû remonter par la rue de rivolie
j'ai de la flotte plein les yeux parce
qu' la vérité je ne sais quel amour
absolu
éternel il faudrait pensere n'exist que
pour elle chaque nuit chaque jour voilà
ce qu'elle voudrait seulement la vie
seulement il y a le temps et le moment
fatal où le Vilin mari tu le prince
charm l'amour son bel amour il neut pas
ch contre un calendrier le battement de
son cœur la douceur de sa
ch je les ai oublié où doncelle parti
voilà qu'il F des cors de mon Dieu
regardez-moi me voilà comme un con de la
Concorde ça y est je la vois attends-moi
c'est moi
attends-moi je
t'aime je
t'aime